est-ce que les smartphones de Huawei
sont morts c'est une vraie question
qu'il faut venir se poser parce que
Huawei était en passe de devenir leader
incontesté dans le monde du smartphone
en 2019 et ils ont été coupés dans leur
élan avec l'embargo américain en mai
2019 aujourd'hui Huawei est toujours là
bien évidemment avec plein de produits
mais également avec des smartphones et
ils m'ont envoyé il y a quelques temps
c'est un petit moment avec moi c'est le
mate 50 pro c'est le fleuron de Huawei
en terme de technologie alors on va
regarder si Huawei est toujours dans la
course il faut aller chez Huawei quels
sont les difficultés il y en a quand
même pas mal et au final est-ce que
Huawei est mort au niveau du smartphone
oui non en 2023 vous êtes prêts allez on
y va
[Musique]
je vous ramène en arrière mai 2019 j'ai
publié cette vidéo directement sur
Youtube le titre c'est Google banni
Huawei pourquoi comment j'ai fait une
belle miniature la mort de Huawei
regardez ça bon vous m'excuserez pour la
miniature j'avais que ça coûte tonnerre
dans le milieu de la tech Google a
purement et simplement banni Huawei à la
suite de lumbago qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé pour Huawei ils ont perdu les
services Google là où ils arrivaient
avec le pro à l'époque souvenez-vous au
final on n'est pas sur un effet waouh on
est sur un effet ah ouais quand même et
c'est très impressionnant avec le P30
pro Google allait devenir leader
incontesté sur le marché du smartphone
il pensait
même lui arriver numéro à rester quand
même pas très très loin pour autant en
mai 2019 ils se sont fait casser les
pattes ils sont perdus les services
Google qu'on a toujours pu avoir sur le
P30 pro mais sur les nouveaux
smartphones qui sont sortis après P40
P50 Nova neuf et compagnie ils les ont
plus donc ça entraîné un vrai
chamboulement directement au niveau de
la marque fatalement ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui quand on va envoyer sur
un nouveau téléphone comme ici le
médecin compte pro et bien ils n'ont pas
les services Google alors pour autant ça
reste un très joli smartphone avec plein
de belles choses à l'intérieur vous avez
un catalogue d'applications propre à
Huawei qui s'appelle ici la galerie il
faut savoir que Huawei quand ils sont
fait bannir de Google ils ne peuvent
plus utiliser les GMS ce sont les Google
Mobile les services ils ont donc déployé
les HMS les Huawei mobile services et en
termes de catalogue d'application on
retrouve ici regardez la galerie alors
la galerie c'est pareil j'en ai déjà
beaucoup parlé mais ça ne s'arrête pas
là parce que maintenant vous avez
téléchargé vos applications directement
dans la galerie pour venir télécharger
de nouvelles applications vous allez
dans la galerie qui s'étude juste ici et
j'ai d'ailleurs également à publier une
interview sur ma chaîne de Stéphane
cortenin qui était à l'époque directeur
marketing de Huawei et qui nous explique
ils allaient aller avec les Huawei
mobile service 6 et notamment la galerie
il y a deux acteurs majeurs aujourd'hui
on a d'un côté Apple avec iOS on a notre
côté Google avec Android est-ce qu'il y
a encore de la place pour un nouvel OS
sauf que quasiment 4 ans après quelque
chose près et bien il y a pas réellement
de gros avancées alors si oui et non il
faut pas être mauvaise langue si vous
venez regarder dans toutes les
applications regarder j'en ai installé
un paquet on a effectivement un snapchat
on avait LC alors akinator si on veut on
a de la outlook on va voir le bon coin
on va avoir Lidl opérat et les 7 jours
la SNCF on va également Air France on va
voir différentes banques la Caisse
d'Epargne la banque populaire le CIC on
a la fnac il y a pas mal d'application
qu'on trouve en natif ici dans la
galerie différents univers que ce soit
des jeux que ce soit des sites d'achat
ici et ça il y en a des tonnes mais vous
n'avez pas tout alors j'ai voulu
comparer par rapport à ce que j'ai
aujourd'hui sur mon iPhone c'est à dire
sur mon iphone j'ai beaucoup
d'applications que je viens mot utilisé
au quotidien je vais venir utiliser
notamment et bien forcément tout ce qui
va être YouTube fatalement mes
différents réseaux sociaux Facebook
Instagram et compagnie pour la
productivité j'utilise notion il y a
toute une partie divertissement tu vas
avoir un Netflix mycanal Disney plus
prime vidéo et compagnie Molotov TV
également pour de la musique du Spotify
donc j'ai voulu faire un point regarder
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui ces applications
je peux venir les trouver très
facilement ici alors oui et non il y a
des applications que j'aurais en natif
directement je peux venir télécharger je
vous ai montré des banques et compagnies
ici et ça il y a deux applications que
je viens de trouver sur des catalogues
d'applications tiers c'est le cas
notamment de Spotify c'est le cas de
Molotov TV que je ne trouverai pas
directement sur mais que j'aurais grâce
à pétale search qui va être la recherche
intelligente le moteur de recherche de
Huawei ils vont venir me le proposer sur
d'autres catalogues d'applications
notamment Spotify Netflix prime vidéo
mycanal insta et compagnie que je vais
pouvoir trouver sur apk Parks donc
beaucoup d'applications ne seront pas
disponibles en natif ici alors pour
autant on va notamment dans un sujet ici
qui a fait clubbing.com que les apk
selon Huawei sont ceux en tout cas tous
les catalogues d'applications qui vont
venir mettre en avant sont sûrs il vous
le mettre en priorité l'utilisateur et
renvoyer vers la source officiel c'est à
dire effectivement vers l'App Store pour
trouver le fameux impeccable pour ceux
qui savent pas un apk c'est un fichier
applicatif comme vous avez sur Windows
le point exe donc c'est à dire c'est une
application vous allez venir installer
ça vous sert à venir installer
l'application et il faut l'avoir sur une
source qui soit officielle ou en tout
cas une source sérieuse sans quoi vous
pouvez avoir une apk qui va installer un
deuxième fichier un cheval de Troie des
virus de la mer bref et compagnie ça on
en veut pas non ça on en veut pas donc
en fait il nous propose des catalogues
d'applications tiers apkpure apk apk
PACS ici la pkpack c'est là où j'ai
trouvé Netflix prime vidéo mycanal insta
et compagnie up to down inazine pas sur
la sécurité nous examinons la popularité
du site et de l'application pour évaluer
la crédibilité nous nous assurons que la
page dispose de la dernière version de
l'application disponible car elle
contient généralement les derniers
correctifs de sécurité à la fin du
processus nous effectuons une
vérification interne pour des recherches
des logiciels malveillants donc bon
normalement tout est sécurisé ça c'est
bien même si effectivement c'est
totalement transparent lorsque vous
venez sur votre smartphone et vous en
rendez pas compte vous le télécharger
directement mais il va peut-être y avoir
des fois des galères au niveau des mises
à jour il va falloir bien vous cherchez
la dernière version pour être sûr
qu'elle fonctionne avoir les derniers
correctifs bref tout est pas transparent
et aussi simple que si vous aviez par
exemple le Google Play Store ou si vous
aviez la forme de votre iPhone donc bon
il y a mais malgré tout on trouve quand
même beaucoup de choses alors oui et non
moi il y a des choses que j'ai pas
trouvé il y a un truc extrêmement
important pour moi c'est notion notion
c'est quoi notion c'est mon outil qui me
permet de venir planifier toutes mes
vidéos et tout mon contenu pour Youtube
je mets tout sur le chant j'ai tout sur
nos chaînes les vidéos que j'ai publié
les idées les cils et ça bref tout est
ici sauf qu'en réalité nos chaînes ici
il le trouve pas vous voyez je fais
marcher nos chaînes rechercher et il y a
pas nos chaînes alors il existe d'autres
alternatives que notion il y a très lot
on va beaucoup moins loin et c'est
beaucoup moins bien je préfère
réellement nos chaînes vous pouvez pour
autant l'utiliser sur votre PC ou sur
votre Mac comme vous voulez mais c'est
dommage parce que moi j'aime beaucoup
voir directement ce qu'il en est sur mon
smartphone lorsque je me balade et là je
ne peux pas donc voyez il y a quand même
aujourd'hui quelques petites limites
d'un point de vue logiciel et ça c'est
dommage autre application qui est
vachement importante pour moi c'est
Lightroom sur lequel je vais venir faire
des retouches alors Lightroom je peux
venir le trouver mais voyez sur un autre
application qui s'appelle apk free
pourquoi pas mais une fois de plus en
termes de mise à jour il va falloir que
moi je vienne les faire manuellement
dans la mesure où ça continuera à
fonctionner allez savoir il y a plein de
jeux populaires qu'on trouvera sur le
Play Store et qu'on trouvera pas sur la
biarrerie donc vous voyez il y a
quelques limites encore aujourd'hui donc
je dirais que aujourd'hui si vous
n'aimez pas à Google si vous n'aimez pas
le Play Store si vous n'aimez pas Apple
si vous n'aimez pas l'App Store et vous
voulez une alternative vous pouvez aller
sur la galerie il y aura pas tout ce
sera à vous de le savoir mais
aujourd'hui les smartphones de Huawei
sont plus des smartphones qui sont
destinés à un public averti il faut que
vous sachiez où vous mettez les pieds
alors là je vous montre le médecin
contrôle mais le mettre 50 pro il est
génial il a un super hardware il est
vraiment très très bien et très très
bien fini mais il a également un autre
problème c'est à dire que le mètre 53 il
est uniquement 4G si vous regardez la
fiche technique sur le site du
constructeur processeur plateforme
mobile 4G c'est un dragon 8 plus Jane 1
le Stade dragon 8 plus Diana si vous le
trouvez sur d'autres smartphones vous
aurez un modem 5G sauf que Huawei comme
ils sont accusés d'espionnage pour le
compte de Pékin ce qui pour l'instant
n'a pas été démontré et bien ils n'ont
pas le droit à la 5G ils ont droit
uniquement à avoir un modem 4G ça veut
dire que vous venez acheter un
smartphone qui vaut
1399 euros sur lequel vous n'avez pas la
5G et si vous mettez 1399 € dans un
smartphone peut-être avez-vous déjà un
abonnement 5G voulez-vous profiter de la
5G et là c'est pas possible alors ça
fait râler parce que ce smartphone il
est vraiment super bon super bien fait
vous avez une très belle dalle au lait
de 6,74 pouces c'est du Full HD plus
taux de rafraîchissement qui va jusqu'à
120 Hertz alors pour autant ici on a pas
une dalle ltpo mais malgré tout elle est
très belle très bien faite légèrement
incurvée finition du smartphone qui sont
irréprochables très très belle alors bon
on se voit bien au travers coucous c'est
moi mais pour autant c'est vraiment un
très très joli smartphone il est très
performant je vous disais avec le SAD
dragon 8 plus Jane 1 l'audio fonctionne
bien l'autonomie est bonne on est 8 Go
de RAM soit 256 soit 512 giga de
stockage il est certifié résistant aux
éclaboussures et à la poussière avec une
certification
IP68 il est très bon en plus de ça au
niveau de la photo vous avez un triple
capteur à l'arrière bon il prend un peu
la poussière mais bon sinon ça va bien
on va avoir un capteur principal de 50
mégapixels un ultra grand angle de 13
mégapixels et puis un téléobjectif de 64
mégapixels et les photos sont très
belles le rendu est hyper qualitatifs
vous montrer quelques photos prises si
et là c'est franchement vachement bien
regardez on peut venir zoomer dans
l'image sans perdre de qualité la
colorimétrie est très belle le rendu est
beau c'est douce et agréable il y a des
couleurs tous les côtés bref j'a
énormément même pour vous shooter de la
nourriture ça donne faim regardez ça me
donne une dalle pas possible je vous
raconte pas j'ai tout bouffé je trouve
ça juste joli ah bon effectivement il y
a quel moment il va venir se perdre un
petit peu mais lorsque vous faites
attention lorsque vous venez shooter de
très belles choses vous avez un rendu
qui est vraiment juste magnifique
regardez ça je ferai pas ce qu'il a
imprimer directement comme ça tellement
c'est beau donc ils ont vraiment une
très très belle maîtrise Huawei au
niveau de la photographie c'est pas
nouveau alors avant ils avaient un
partenariat avec Leica aujourd'hui c'est
plus eux qui l'ont c'est Xiaomi qui a
son partenariat avec Leica et on l'a
notamment ici au niveau du Xiaomi 13 pro
mais pour autant le rendu photographique
nous propose ici Huawei est juste
sublime ça marche vraiment bien regardez
le détail au niveau des vagues on a des
gens qui sont vraiment très très belle
une très bonne gestion de la lumière
bref c'est un très joli photophone et on
fait de très jolies choses deux jours
comme de nuit je vous montre quelques
petites images regardez et c'est vrai
que il y a un très très beau rendu ici
donc on peut pas se planter garder sur
de la nourriture une fois de plus ça
marche bien il y a pas beaucoup de
lumière mais ça fonctionne vraiment très
très bien regardez-moi ce poulpe là on a
envie de le manger sur du bœuf aussi
c'est magnifique sur du dessert là c'est
synapson qui joue en concert parfait on
a envie de danser sur des vannes et
alors j'ai même vous montrer ça c'est
une petite session de surf là c'est moi
dans la flotte du coup regardez je suis
tout petit ici et bien regardez on a
ceux qui sont quand même plutôt sympa et
on peut venir zoomer alors si vous venez
transmet vous allez voir comment ça va
plus fonctionner mais on peut faire des
trucs sympas donc ça c'est quand même
vachement cool alors regardez hein c'est
effectivement le problème de ce zoom
périscopique à un moment peut se
rapprocher mais globalement ça sert plus
à rien mais regardez le rendu des photos
comme c'est super beau donc voilà une
fois de plus ils ont une vraie très très
belle maîtrise ici au niveau de la
photographie et ça marche vachement bien
on a un très beau boke très beau fou
derrière plan bref c'est cool c'est beau
ça marche bien bon côté vidéo on peut
faire des choses aussi c'est pas
forcément ce qui sera le mieux mais on
peut venir faire des choses si on a
envie de venir s'amuser c'est également
un petit vidéophone qui est très sympa
même pour filmer de la nourriture ça
fonctionne bon en revenant zoomer trop
près là il y a un moment ça passe plus
mais globalement la qualité est là et ça
fonctionne donc ça c'est quand même
vachement bien donc pour moi ce
smartphone le mate 50 Pro est un
excellent photophone un excellent
smartphone avec de très belles finitions
et qui n'a absolument pas à rougir
devant les autres smartphones maintenant
le problème c'est quand on a quasiment
1400 euros à mettre sur un smartphone
est-ce qu'on va acheter un smartphone il
n'a pas les services Google est-ce qu'on
va acheter un smartphone qui n'a pas la
5G je pense ça peut être un moment un
peu limitatif maintenant chez Huawei il
y a plein d'autres smartphones on veut
pas forcément acheter le mettre 50 pro
qui est d'ailleurs à partir de 1199
euros alors d'ailleurs pour information
Huawei font également des smartphones
pliable le mate 16 2 bon sera à peu près
la même histoire on est quasiment à 1000
balles mais vous avez des tarifs plus
contenus le Nova 9 qui est très joli un
super smartphone à partir de 329 € vous
avez également le Nova neuf se
de 99 € et puis il y en a d'autres le
Nova y70 le Nova 8i les tarifs diminuent
et puis vous avez les séries y donc il y
en a tous les tarifs mais dans
l'équation ce sera toujours la même
chose c'est-à-dire un smartphone avec la
galerie avec pétales search et sans les
services Google alors une fois de plus
je vous invite à venir regarder mes
autres vidéos je vous en parlais parce
que vous pouvez installer les web app
pour utiliser Youtube pour utiliser
Google vous pouvez intégrer directement
votre messagerie dans votre logiciel de
messagerie sur votre smartphone donc là
il y a absolument pas de problème ça
marchera bien mais regardez une fois de
plus tous ces smartphones là
fonctionnent sans les services Google
d'ailleurs dites-moi vous est-ce que
vous seriez prêt à acheter un smartphone
de Huawei sans les services Google et
c'est là où c'est intéressant parce que
Huawei propose effectivement des
smartphones mais ils n'ont pas que des
smartphones ils ont également des
ordistes et c'était beaucoup de PC
portable de Huawei ça marche vachement
bien et autant sur les smartphones ils
n'ont pas les services Google autant sur
les PC il continue à bosser avec les
États-Unis vous avez Windows il y a les
licence ça marche il y a absolument
aucun problème j'en ai testé un paquet
pour venir regarder les P40 les montres
les montres qui marchent aussi pas mal
alors les mondes c'est pareil le point
faible ça va être là catalogue
d'application mais par contre vous avez
des très grosses autonomies derrière et
ça va vachement loin j'ai testé alors ça
c'était il y a un an le matebook 14 s
qui marche vachement bien les moniteurs
sont aussi très bien le madeview GT les
madeviews sont super bien hyper canon
les mailspad les tablettes sont pas mal
également sauf que vous aurez la même
problématique que vous allez dans les
smartphones c'est-à-dire pas de
catalogue d'applications de Google mais
book 16 mailbook eux sont très cool le
MacBook 16 est très bien donc vous voyez
que chez Huawei il y a vachement de
solution au niveau des PC et si vous
cherchez un PC vous pouvez y aller les
yeux fermés donc en fait Huawei il a dit
et on le voit ici dans cet article de
frandroid c'est vachement intéressant
c'est-à-dire qu'ils vous disent en fait
que sur une de leurs dernières
présentations on se parle ici du
printemps 2022 attention c'est il y a un
petit moment et bien ils ont mis sur une
conférence de près de 45 minutes
seulement 12 minutes et 27 secondes ils
ont vraiment chronométré était consacré
au smartphone et en fait ils mettent
vraiment le paquet sur les whereable
c'est à dire sur les montres connectés
notamment sur tout ce qui va être santé
et bien évidemment sur les ordinateurs
sur les PC c'est William Tian président
de Huawei pour l'Europe qui a déclaré à
Milan à ce moment-là comme vous le savez
nous sommes en difficulté sur les
smartphones nous allons nous concentrer
davantage sur le home mon fils les
whereable mais nous n'allons pas
abandonner le commerce de smartphone
même si les smartphones ne sont plus la
priorité aujourd'hui chez Huawei Huawei
reste dans la place avec de très jolis
produits très bien fini donc extrêmement
sérieux allez savoir comment tout ça va
évoluer à l'avenir allez savoir c'est
vraiment une question intéressante le
secret et la solution pour venir
progresser et évoluer ici c'est quoi et
bien c'est d'avoir de plus en plus
d'applications dans leur catalogue
d'applications la galerie mais pour que
les développeurs viennent passer du
temps ils viennent investir parce que
c'est
n'investit pour un nouveau catholique
d'application et bien il faut qu'il y
ait des usagers et pour qu'il y ait des
usagers il faut qu'il y ait des
applications donc vous voyez c'est un
espèce de cercle vicieux Huawei investi
beaucoup d'argent pour développer sur
son catalogue d'application il y en a de
plus en plus vous le voyez elles y sont
pas toutes maintenant c'est à vous de me
le dire est-ce que vous vous verriez
venir sur un smartphone de Huawei tout
en sachant que vous n'allez pas avoir
forcément peut-être toutes vos
applications les savoirs d'ailleurs ça
dépend de vous d'ailleurs dites moi si
vous avez toutes vos applications ici
oui ou non est-ce que vous seriez prêt à
faire le sacrifice de ne pas avoir 5 g
pour avoir un smartphone de Huawei ou
alors pas du tout marquez moi ça dans
les commentaires on en reparlera bien
évidemment de Huawei parce que c'est une
super marque qui a de très très belles
finitions qui sait fabriquer des
smartphones et puis une fois de plus je
vous le dis ce mate 50 pro étant super
smartphone super photophone très
performant qui est vraiment juste génial
je l'adore il est vraiment très bien
fait il a deux défauts principaux un il
n'a pas les services Google donc à
savoir si ça peut vous intéresser oui ou
non et deux il n'a pas la 5G ça peut
faire râler dites moi ce que vous en
pensez dans les commentaires on se
retrouve très vite pour continuer à
parler de texte je vous embrasse prenez
soin de vous Ciao
[Musique]